[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN NAIM: Good
afternoon everyone.
My name is Alan Naim.
I am a product
manager at Google.
I work on Google
Container Engine.
And I'm joined here by
David Oppenheimer, who's
a lead software engineer for
Kubernetes and Google Container
Engine, and he's
going to be presenting
with me on the demos.
So how's everybody doing today?
Good?
Friday, all set.
Hope you're having
a good conference.
So the title of our
talk today is really--
it's around best
practices associated
with managing Container Engine
Clusters across multiple teams.
So show of hands, how many
people here are actually
running containers
in production?
That's pretty impressive.
All right, I guess
there's so much
excitement around containers
and production that the system--
and then of folks that
are running containers
in production, who
is using Kubernetes?
And keep your hands up.
Who's using Kubernetes
is in production?
All right, awesome.
So the agenda today
is really around--
let's start by talking about how
you would run Container Engine
Clusters across multiple teams.
We're going to break the
talk into three pieces,
and the first piece is really
about Kubernetes resource
hierarchies.
So those of you that are
running on Google Cloud,
you understand the
concept of a project,
and then you have a cluster.
And we're going to walk through
some best practices around what
we're seeing out
there with customers
that we're talking
to, around how
they package these components
within these hierarchies.
Secondary is really around
resource management.
So now that you have
your cluster or clusters,
how do you run heterogeneous
applications that
have different
resource requirements
and share those resources
so that the applications are
getting the best
quality of service
associated with their needs?
And then finally, we're going
to talk about role based
access control and Kubernetes,
and walk through some
of the features that we
have, in particular in 1.6,
that enables finer
level granularity
around applying axis control
to something like a cluster
namespace.
And then throughout
the talk I'll
be inviting David Oppenheimer
up to take everything
that I'm presenting
and make it real,
show you a demo of how it works.
So let's get started.
So those of you that are
familiar with Kubernetes
know that this is
something that is based
on 10 years of
experience Google's
had in running and
managing containers.
We took all these various
best practices associated
with how we do things and
applied it to today's world,
an open sources project
called Kubernetes,
that's run today by the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation.
It's 100% open source, written
in Go, and it'll run anywhere.
So these are things to
remember about Kubernetes.
For those of you that
are moving to the cloud
and going down
that journey, this
is an opportunity to
really have a central way
of doing things and deploying
these hermetically type
environments that
are very predictable
across different environments.
So as you all know,
containers are great.
They add a lot of value, but
typically after the first five
hours, you encounter challenges
around scale, health checks.
How do you get containers
networked together,
and how do you
operate an environment
and ensure you're able to push
things into production quickly,
and do rolling updates, and
all these various things.
How do you take
containers that typically
don't have any notion of data,
and attach volumes to them,
and manage the entire life
cycle of these things?
This is where
Kubernetes comes in,
and it provides this
environment, this platform
for you, in terms of running and
managing containers at scale.
So this was my 101 two-minute
on Kubernetes, assuming
most of you already understand
bits and pieces of it,
and you're interested
mostly in around,
how do you manage
different clusters
across different teams?
So the typical Kubernetes
journey usually starts with,
hey, we're getting
into containers,
we need an orchestrator.
Let's find an
application that we
think makes a good
fit for containers,
and let's go ahead and
do proof of concept.
You identify a
group of developers.
They take their
application, they
containerize, they
run it on Kubernetes.
A month later you show it
to the rest of the team
and everybody's like, this
is cool, this is awesome.
How do we get some of this?
Another team comes
along and says, hey,
we want access to this cluster.
So in some cases you'd let
them spin up their own cluster,
in other cases you basically
give them access to the sandbox
cluster that they
go to town with
and try and run their
applications and so on.
Then you get to the
point where, OK, we're
ready to go to production.
Now what?
Right?
There's some choices that you
have to make at this point,
and some of you I've talked
to are facing these things.
One choice is-- do I
create a project per team?
Do I create a cluster per team?
Do I run one shared
cluster and have
teams run their own namespace?
What do I do?
I have requirements that
have different regulatory
requirements.
Do I put them in a
different cluster,
in a different project?
How should I look at
these requirements,
and what's the best practice
associated with that?
There's really no
single perfect answer.
It all comes down to how your
organization's structured,
how your teams are structured,
and really, the requirements
of the application.
So what I want to
do is just walk you
through some examples of
things that we see out there
and then provide you our opinion
around some best practices.
So one common example
we see out there
is you have one
project and one cluster
and then different name
spaces, and these name spaces
map to different
applications, different teams.
So we see quite a bit of that.
The pros is it's
very easy to manage.
It's a single cluster context
that you're dealing with,
and you're basically running
all your applications
using that single context.
There's cost savings
associated with it.
You're taking advantage of
the namespace for isolation.
So you're able to pack more
resources into that one
cluster.
So you're getting some
potential cost savings.
Your resource
isolation is really
based on the namespace
quota that you're defining,
and we'll talk a bit
about that later on.
And then you can take advantage
of some of the features
that we'll talk about later that
we introduced in Kubernetes 1.6
that applies role based access
control to the namespace
itself.
Some of the cons associated
with that is you're
limited in terms of
what you can isolate
from a namespace perspective--
compute and memory.
So if you want to isolate
with more resources,
these things are
not available yet.
And really, you're basically
leveraging that quota
on that namespace as
the only parameter
for doing the isolation.
So that's one example.
Another example is you have
one project but then different
clusters.
And this one we
actually see the most.
So in this particular case,
you have a staging cluster,
or potentially like a
Def test staging cluster,
and then you have
a prod cluster.
And within each one
of these clusters
you have different
applications that
run in their own namespace.
Some pros with this is
you now have the ability
to isolate some of
the cluster resources.
Like your master
is isolated from
the masters for
staging and test.
You're not exposing your master
to potential DDoS attack that
could happen all of a sudden.
You have the ability now to
run two different networks.
So you're not sharing
that same network
across these two different
operating environments.
You can basically have dedicated
virtual machines and DNS
service for each one
of these environments.
So this is something that
we see quite a bit of
and typically it meets,
say, 80% of the requirements
for companies that
we're talking to.
And then the other important
one from advantages,
a cluster can be
deployed in a single zone
or it can be deployed
across multiple zones.
So in prod you might want to
deploy across multiple zones.
In dev tests you probably want
to deploy in a single zone.
So you have the ability to
assign different availability
characteristics across
these cluster environments.
Disadvantage,
again, you lose some
of the management benefits.
So you're managing
two different clusters
and you have to manage across
different contexts and so on.
The third case is really
different project,
different cluster, and
different namespace.
This is something that we
see with some of the bigger
organizations that want to put
their production environment
in a separate project.
And the advantage for that
is you have your own quotas,
and these quotas really are
your compute engine quotas
that you can
allocate specifically
for that particular project.
Somebody running
dev test staging
can't come along and
consume your quota.
The next thing you know your
application has a spike.
And you're calling your cloud
provider, and you're like, hey,
I need for you to
increase my limits.
And you're like, these
things take time.
Another advantage is if
you're doing chargeback.
Today, unfortunately,
there's really
no way within a cluster
to do chargeback
based on applications that are
running within that cluster.
So you'd have to run
it in its own project
and then do chargeback
based on the billing
that you get for that
particular project.
In the future this
is an area that we're
very interested in
addressing, but for today,
if you have requirement
around chargeback,
run it in its own project.
And then greater control around
identity and access management,
definitely.
And again, like
the previous slide,
you lose some of the
management benefits
because now you're dealing
with multiple projects,
multiple clusters.
But you can take advantage
of some of the things
that we've introduced
around cross project
networking and all
these various things
that we're doing in
Google Cloud Platform that
are very beneficial.
So suggested best practice
is really run your production
environment separate project,
put your dev test staging
in their own project,
split them up
based on clusters
depending on your needs,
and then use namespaces to
break out your applications
within that cluster.
And here's just a list
of the recommendations
that I just mentioned.
So most customers create
cluster per environment,
and then this is just a
repeat of what I just said.
Complete isolation
across namespace
is something that's
still a work in progress.
We'd love to hear your feedback
on some of your requirements
in this space.
So after the talk
please tell us.
So let's talk about resource
control and resource
management.
So most of you probably
understand what a pod is,
but for those of you
that don't, any time
you have containers
that potentially need
to be tightly coupled, or share
a network, or share volumes,
you put those
containers in a pod.
So pod is this
architectural pattern
that was introduced
in Kubernetes
that really is about how you
run and deploy containers.
It is a unit of scale.
Everything that you run in
Kubernetes runs inside a pod.
And when your
application scales,
it is these pods
that are actually
scaling across the nodes
within your cluster.
So everything within a pod
lives and dies together,
and basically it's how you
deploy your application
in Kubernetes.
What we've done with
Kubernetes is give you
the ability to isolate
some of these resources.
And today we have
various compute resources
that we expose to enable
you to do some isolation
terms of the containers that
you're deploying in Kubernetes.
So some examples
are CPU and memory.
So based on your application's
CPU and memory requirements,
you can specify these when
you create your containers,
and then the scheduler
will automatically
apply the right quality of
service for your application,
depending on how much CPU
and memory that you require.
In the future we're looking
at also extending this
to local storage.
So why would you need
strong isolation for pods?
Well, suppose you have
certain applications
that are running in
the same cluster,
but you want to
ensure that they don't
interfere with each other.
You would isolate your
pods, and this goes back
to the whole notion of cgroups.
Those of you that
use Google Cloud
and sometimes understand the
fact that our virtual machine
spin up very quickly, it's
because our virtual machines
actually run inside containers.
And the fact that you don't
see a lot of noisy neighbor
issues with Google Cloud
Platform, and a lot of this
has some of the
benefits associated
with using cgroups and so on.
Better predictability.
By isolating your
pods, you're actually
able to-- for
certain applications
that you want guaranteed, be
able to specify that and ensure
that they're always
going to be able to run.
A web serving application
and a monitoring application
are critical for your business.
So you can't handle a situation
where you can't schedule a web
service application.
Some of the cons
associated with it
would be oftentimes
you don't know
what your application needs.
Perhaps you don't have
the historical data,
and it's not trivial to actually
figure these things out.
We've tried to make it easier,
but oftentimes you just
have to start with, perhaps,
no isolation and then learn
as your application's running.
Look at cases where you
have evictions, and based
on these evictions, figure
out, and tune, and tweak,
and figure out what the
right limits for setting
for your pods and containers.
And then utilization--
when you isolate,
you're actually perhaps
reducing your efficiency.
Because you're asking
for guarantees,
and your application
may not take advantage
of all these guarantees.
So there might be some
unused resources that end up
lowering your efficiency.
So we have this
concept of what's
called a request and limit.
So when you create a
container you basically
specify a request, and a request
is how much resource, actually,
does my application need.
And you specify
this in CPU and RAM.
That's pretty much it.
So you can actually
specify these things
at container creation time.
Now, suppose that you want to
oversubscribe or overcommit.
We have this other
parameter, actually,
that's called a limit.
And if you set your limit
greater than your request,
then you're actually
overpromising.
Similar to an airline
that overbooks and assumes
not everybody is going
to show up to the gate,
and if everybody
shows up to the gate,
someone is going to get
pushed to the next plane
or given a free ticket.
So these two parameters,
request and limit,
are things that you can
configure at the container
level.
Now, a pod actually inherits
all these requests and limits
that are defined at
the container level.
So a pod request becomes the sum
of all the container requests,
and a pod limit becomes the sum
of all the container limits.
OK.
So based on your
request and limits,
the scheduler actually figures
out what the quality of service
is for your pod.
So if you set your
request greater than zero,
but you set your request
equal to your limit--
so you don't want
overcommit, you
don't want oversubscription.
You set those two
values as equal.
Your pod is actually going
to be guaranteed to run.
Now, if you set your request
to be a certain value
but then set your limit
greater than your request,
then your pod is going
to get what's called
a burstable quality of service.
Meaning that if there are
no available resources,
it will do best effort.
It will try to deploy
this pod on these nodes,
but there's no real guarantee.
Now, by default, if you
don't specify anything
and you just keep
your requests at zero
or don't provide any
value, then your pods
are scheduled what's
called best effort.
And they're the ones
that will typically
get evicted first when you
don't have enough resources.
So in the order of eviction,
it's best effort, burstable,
and then guaranteed.
Now, your namespaces also
have requests and limits
that you can specify.
So you provide these
requests and limits
on the namespace level.
And what actually happens
is now all of the requests
and limits associated with
all pods that are running
within that namespace, you're
guaranteeing that they will not
exceed that quota limit
that you're specifying
at the namespace level.
So a good use case is if you
have different teams that
are sharing a cluster, they
each have their own namespace.
One team you know
traditionally has
gone off and done some
things that literally
are unpredictable, and gone
off and did some resource
utilization.
They haven't shared much
insight with you in the past.
Well, you can set a quota
limit for their namespace
and just kind of ring fence
them in terms of usage.
So how would you overcommit
resources on the cluster?
So one way to do so,
as I mentioned earlier,
is on your container.
For your container, set your
limit higher than your request.
And once you do that,
you will actually now
have the ability to
promise more resources
than what's available.
This is good for things like
burstable type workloads.
Perhaps you want to take
advantage of as much efficiency
as possible.
For pods that you think
always need to run,
always have to be
up and running,
then you basically
set your request
equal to your limit
for those containers,
and those will get guaranteed.
Best practice is--
oftentimes most of us
don't know what the
limits and requests are.
We don't know what
our applications
are going to consume.
So start with best
effort or even burstable,
and then see how
things come along,
and then keep track
of pod evictions.
And when you see a particular
pod getting evicted more
than others, then you know
there's something wrong,
and perhaps take that pod
and set it as guaranteed.
And then there could be other
pods that literally are--
they can handle failure.
They don't really need to
be running all the time.
Set those as best effort,
so more like the batch type
workloads.
So let's move to
the demo, and I'm
going to invite David on
stage to walk through it.
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: OK.
Thanks, Alan.
Can we switch to the
input from the PC?
Perfect.
OK.
I'm going to try to make this--
can people see?
Well, it's right at the top.
Is that large enough?
I can make it a
little bit larger.
Let's start and
see how this goes.
So I'm going to show two demos--
one of the quota functionality
that Alan talked about,
and then I'll show
you one of resource isolation.
So the quota demo, it's
pretty straightforward.
Can people see this?
I can make it one
more level bigger if--
yes, no?
It's good enough.
OK.
People are saying
it's good enough.
So we're going to
create a namespace just
to run this demo in.
And to start with,
you'll see that there's
no quota associated
with the namespace.
By the way, this
command kubectl,
is the command line
client that you
use to interact with
a Kubernetes cluster.
And so we're saying
here, tell me
what quotas are associated
with this namespace
called demos that
we just created,
and it's saying there's no
quota associated with it.
And so let's set up a quota.
And the way you set up
a quota in Kubernetes,
in Container Engine,
is that you create
a yaml file that defines
a resource quota object
and specifies the quota.
Like Alan said
before, you can set
a quota for the total
amount of requests,
or total amount of limit,
or total number of pods
that are allowed in a namespace.
So this quota is fairly simple.
It's saying that we're going
to set a quota of 2 CPU
and 2 gigs of memory, maximum,
across all of the pods that are
going to run in this namespace.
So that's what the
file looks like,
and then we run cube control to
push that file into the server,
which will create the quota.
So now we've created the quota,
and let's see how it works.
Before we do that, we'll run
this kubectl describe, which
will show us what
quota we've installed.
And you can see it says
that there is a quota called
demo quota that's associated
with the demo's namespace,
and there are zero resources,
zero CPU and memory
resources in use right
now, and the quota
is 2 CPU and 2 gigs of memory.
So first we're going to create a
pod that uses 60% of the quota,
and that should succeed
because you're allowed
to use up to 100% of a quota.
This is the yaml
definition of a pod.
It's very simple.
It's saying that the pod should
run in the demo namespace,
or the demo's namespace.
I don't know if I highlight
stuff if you can see it.
Yeah, I guess you probably can.
That's what this line is doing.
The pod has a name,
and it's saying
that we're going to run this
very simple test pod called
hostname that just is a server
that serves the hostname if you
connect to it in this pod.
And then we're setting
these resource requirements
on the pod.
Like Alan said before, you can
associate limits and requests
with your containers.
Here we're just going to
associate a limit with
the container because Kubernetes
defaults the request to be
equal to the limit if
you don't specify it,
and it fits better on
the screen if we don't.
But what will
happen is that when
we create this, both the
limits and the request
will be set to 1.2 CPU and 1.2
gigs of memory, which again,
is 60% of the quota.
So now that was just showing you
what the yaml file looks like.
Now we actually ask
kubectl to create that pod,
and it says the pod was created.
So it was created successfully.
We can run kubectl describe.
And there is tons
of output here,
but you can see that it says
that the pod is running.
And you can see that
the limits are 1.2.
By the way, these units,
the M is Milli CPU,
and the M for the memory
is also like millibytes.
I'm not sure that that's
as useful as Milli CPUs.
But anyway, it's showing
that the limits are
1.2 CPU and 1.2 gigs of
memory, and the request
is 1.2 CPU and 1.2 gigs of
memory, and the pod is running.
By the way, all of the
demos that I'm showing
are running against
a live cluster.
Obviously the typing part
has been pre-scripted,
but everything that
we're doing here
is actually running
against a live cluster.
So that was just to show
you the pod is running.
And now we can try to
create another pod that's
also going to use
60% of the quota,
and this should fail because
then 120% of the quota
would be in use.
So this is another pod.
It has a different name, but
it's otherwise identical.
Has same resource limits and
same resource requirements.
So we ask Kubernetes
to create this pod,
and then it gives an error.
It says, you tried to create
this pod but it was forbidden
because it exceeded the quota.
You requested such and such
amount of CPU and memory,
and then it tells you how
much was already in use
and what the quota limit was.
And so then you
can see why it was
rejected for using more than--
it would have used
more than the limit
if the system had
allowed you to create it.
Oh, and this is just to show
that the pod was actually not
created.
We do kubectl describe
to show us the pod,
and the pod is not
found because it
was rejected at
creation time due to it
would have exceeded the quota.
So then the last piece
is just to show you
that we can create a pod
that uses 30% of the quota
because then a total
of 90% will be in use.
So this is, again, a third pod
identical to the first two,
except the limits--
you can see down at the bottom,
0.6 CPU, 0.6 gigs of memory.
We create that.
It says it was
successfully created.
And then when we run
kubectl describe,
you can see that it's running
and has the requests and limits
that we specified.
And lastly, we can ask
Kubernetes to tell us
how much quota is in use by
using this kubectl describe
on the quota object,
and that tells us
both how much is in
use and how much is
the maximum amount of quota.
So since we asked
for 60% and then 30%,
you can see 90% of the CPU quota
and 90% of the memory quota
are in use.
So that's a pretty
simple demo just
to show you how you can set
resource quotas on namespaces,
the namespace granularity
for limit, for request.
I didn't show number of pods,
but you can also set quotas
on the number of pods that
can be created in a namespace
to limit that resource as well.
So I'm going to shift to
a second resource demo.
And then after
that, Alan's going
to continue with the
next part of the talk.
The second resource related
demo that I'm going to show you
will be about
resource isolation,
which is one of the things
that Alan talked about.
The way that Kubernetes is able
to guarantee that containers
that have that guaranteed
quality of service
are able to run
and not be evicted
is that they constrain
the amount of resources
that other containers
can use, and that
is done based on the limit.
So as Alan mentioned,
the request
is the amount of resources
that you tell the scheduler
that you need, and that amount
is always guaranteed to you.
It always puts the
pod on a machine
that has enough
resources to guarantee
that that request is satisfied.
And then the limit can be
higher than the request
if you want to do
overcommitment.
But the limit is where
the system essentially
cuts you off.
Like if you exceed
your memory limit,
then the system will
kill your container.
If you exceed the CPU limit,
it will throttle the container.
And these enforcement
mechanisms are the way
that the system can then
provide the guarantees
to the guaranteed
quality of service pods.
So I'm going to do a quick
demo to show you that.
We're going to, again, create
a namespace for this demo,
and we're going to run a
container that just turns up
a bunch of memory and CPU.
So what we're doing here, I'll
explain what this is doing.
It's going to set the limits to
0.5 CPU and 200 megs of memory,
and then the amount of resources
that it's actually going to use
is going to be 150 megs
of memory and 2 CPUs.
So for this first
part of the demo,
it'll be a container
that is using
less memory than the limit
but more CPU than its limit.
And you'll see what happens.
So first, let's do
kubectl describe
to verify that it's running.
And we can see
that it's running,
and the limits and requests
are 500 Milli CPU--
so 0.5 CPU.
And also you see
the memory there.
And then we can look
at the container usage.
So unfortunately, this takes
a minute or so to start up.
But in a minute, once
this has started up,
you'll see that the actual
usage, the CPU usage,
is constrained to
be within the limit.
So just to recap again how
this container was configured,
it's going to try to use 2 CPU.
That's what this dash
CPU's 2 is saying.
It's going to try to
use 2 CPU, but the limit
is set at 0.5 CPU.
And so the resource
isolation in the kernel level
should prevent it from
using more than 0.5 CPUs.
So hopefully this is
working now, which it is.
[COUGHS]
Pardon, me.
And you can see that
it's using 500 Milli
CPU and the full
amount of memory
it requested, because
that was within its limit.
But the CPU is being
constrained to 500 Milli CPU.
This command, by the way,
that I ran, this kubectl top,
it's a very cool command.
It will show you the resource
usage of your containers
running in the cluster.
And so like Alan was
talking before about how
if you want to provide
good resource isolation,
it's useful to provide these
resource requests and limits,
but you may not know the first
time you run your application
how to set those.
And so this kubectl
top command is
very useful for identifying how
much resources your container
is using, and you can
watch that over time.
You can also, of
course, use a monitoring
tool like Stackdriver
and Container Engine,
or something like
that, and then use
that to set the
requests and limits.
But anyway, that's what
this kubectl top command is.
So then the second
thing that I'll show--
that was showing how limits
can limit the CPU consumption
by throttling if the container
tries to exceed the CPU limit.
And then the second
part is to show you
that if you try to
exceed your memory limit,
then your container will
get killed by the system.
So here we're going to
run another container.
We deleted the first one.
And this one we're setting
the memory limit at 200 meg,
and we're going to use 250 meg.
In other words, the
container is going
to try to use more memory
than specified in the limit.
And you can see here when
we do the kubectl get pods,
it shows that the container
was killed due to exceeding
its memory limit.
This says restarts one because
Kubernetes will automatically--
this container was configured
to automatically restart
on failure, and so it's going
to restart the container.
Sometimes people want
containers to restart
even if they use
too much memory,
because they know they
have a memory leak
and they just want the system
to periodically restart it,
which is one way to
deal with memory leaks.
And so you can also set
the container to not
restart in this condition.
But anyway, this is just
showing that now it's
restarted a second time.
Again, it's showing you
the status was that it
exceeded the memory limit.
And we do it a third time, and
now it's in this crash loop
back off state, which is to
prevent the system from just--
like all the resources
on the system
from being consumed, restarting
the container over and over
again.
It notices that it's killed
it a couple of times already,
and then it will
continue restarting it
but at a slower and
slower rate to prevent
consuming all the resources
on just doing restarts.
And here we caught
it on the third try.
It's in the running state.
You get the idea.
This is just showing that
you can do kubectl describe.
And it will show you--
like if you walk
up to the system
and you wonder why the
site's not running,
you can see that it
says that the last state
of this container was
a terminated state.
And the reason was that it
was killed due to exceeding
the memory limit.
So that's the end of the demo.
That is just showing you that
we use resource isolation
techniques in the
kernel to limit
the resource consumption for
memory and CPU of containers.
And the reason that's
useful is so that then we
can provide the guarantees
to the other containers that
are requesting resources.
Yeah.
So I'll let Alan come
back up and continue
with the next part of the talk.
ALAN NAIM: Thank you, David.
Awesome demo.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's switch back to the slides.
So there's also this
resource or object
that we have in Kubernetes
called initial resource.
Originally I talked
about the case
where you're
deploying a container,
but you actually don't know
how much to set your request
or how much to set your limit.
Well, you can take advantage
of this initial resource, which
actually is learning how
your container is utilizing
resources and will set
the appropriate request
and limit for your container.
This is only available today
in Kubernetes open source,
but it will make its way into--
it's currently an alpha feature.
It will make its way into
Container Engine shortly.
So the idea here
is think of a world
where you have
containers that you're
provisioning and scheduling.
You're taking advantage
of initial resources
to do some learning around
resource utilization,
and then you plug that all into
the horizontal pod auto scaler,
and then plug down into
the cluster auto scaling.
So you have the system
now that's operating.
Everything is automated,
but it's running itself.
And that's the goal in terms
of what a lot of customers
want to achieve.
And we provided these
patterns for you
to be able to start
taking steps towards that.
So in terms of where we're
going with cluster resource
management--
as I mentioned earlier,
we're looking at adding disk
as a first class resource.
There's some work that's
being done around GPU support
as well that will make its
way into Container Engine.
Our goal is to really
give you the ability
to extend these resources.
So perhaps there are
certain resources
that you want to meter by or
do resource management by.
So you could extend your API
and bring those resources along.
Things like usage
base scheduling
is another area
we're looking at.
Dedicated nodes, so
environments where, perhaps, you
have different organizations
that are doing things
very differently, but you'd like
to allocate n number of nodes
for each one of
these organizations
and ensure that everything
that they schedule actually
goes on those nodes.
So you're actually getting
intra-cluster node isolation.
So it's a pretty powerful
thing that we're investing in.
Priority preemption,
that's another area,
and then improving the quality
of service enforcement.
Today, it's really
around the containers,
but bring some of these
things up to the pod level.
And then Linux disk code is
for tracking in isolation
and then node
allocatable enforcements.
Those are areas
we're going into.
And if you're interested in
learning more about these,
please reach out to myself
and David after this talk.
So let's switch gears into
identity and access management.
So today, Kubernetes
is 1.5, and we're
going to be releasing
1.6 very shortly.
So today, most of the identity
and access management roles
that are defined at
the project level
really apply to the
Kubernetes cluster itself.
If you want finer grain control
around things like namespaces,
that was not available in
Kubernetes 1.5 or earlier.
So the idea with project level
identity access management,
you have these roles that you
define within your project,
and now you can associate
them with your clusters.
So for example, how we typically
see people doing things
is taking these roles that
are predefined, like container
developer, container admin,
container viewer, and defining
groups, and these groups
that map to specific teams
within your organization.
And then specifying the
right level of permission
for a Container Engine Cluster
associated with these groups
that you're defining.
So in this example, you
have a developer group
that maps to container developer
IM role that maps to a dev
project, and you set
the specific permissions
around that.
So that was available today.
In Kubernetes 1.6,
we're introducing
this concept of role
based access control down
to the namespace level.
So David will come up on stage
in a minute or so to walk you
through a demo here.
But what he'll be
showing you is basically
the ability to have an
admin come along, reach out
to John who is on the blue team,
and then basically provide John
with access to the
blue team namespace.
Come along and Lisa, who
is on the green team,
ensure that Lisa only
has read/write access
to the green team namespace.
And you can even take
it one step further
and say, well, I want Lisa
to have actually view access
into the blue team namespace.
So as you can see, that
level of granularity
is actually improved
in terms of what
you can do in really connecting
service accounts, and users,
and roles to the underlying
resources within a cluster.
And eventually we want to
take that even further.
So without further ado, I
will hand it back to David
for a namespace
access control demo.
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: OK.
Great.
So in this demo, we're
going to use three windows.
Because as Alan
mentioned, we're going
to show how you can have
an administrator, and then
this blue user, and
this green user,
and they all have different
access permissions.
So hopefully it
will be clear enough
when I'm jumping around
between the windows.
And also, one thing
I wanted to mention
is that the different
users are going
to be based on having
different service accounts.
It's a little tricky
on a single machine
to be logged in as multiple
users at the same time.
So what I'll show you is
based on these users having
different service accounts
associated with them,
but in the real world
you can also just
have them be based on
users without having
to create service accounts.
So the first window here
is going to be the admin.
And they're going to run
this Gcloud command to ask
the Google Cloud Platform IAM
service to create a service
account for the blue dev.
You don't have to worry
about the details here.
It's just saying create
a service account
and then fetch the
key into a local file.
We're going to do the same
thing for the green team dev,
create a service account called
green team dev at such and such
and such, and then fetch
the key into a local file.
Then we're going to go over
here into the blue team window--
sorry, the windows
aren't color coded,
but I'll tell you what
I'm switching to--
and fetch configure kubectl
to use the credentials
that we just set up for
the blue service account.
This is all just
setup stuff so far.
Last bit of setup--
we're going to go into the
third window for the green user
and fetch the data into
the kubectl config file
so that now the green
user has the credentials
for the green service account.
So now we can actually start
doing interesting things.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is to create a namespace
that's called blue.
And what you'll see is that
the blue team dev shouldn't
have any access
to that namespace
yet because we haven't
explicitly granted permissions.
So we're in the second
window now, the blue window,
and we do kubectl get
pods, namespace blue,
and you can see that the
server gives an error saying
that the blue user
is not allowed
to do this operation
on the blue namespace.
But we can now go back to
the admins window-- oh sorry,
I didn't make these larger.
I probably should have
asked about that earlier.
Luckily you didn't
miss too much.
That might be too
big-- but anyway.
So we go back to
the admin window,
and now we can do the fun part
and give the blue user access
to the blue namespace and using
the role-based access control
mechanism.
So the role-based
access control mechanism
is based on the concept
of cluster roles,
and we have a number
of predefined cluster
roles in Container Engine, like
admin, edit, view, and so on.
This is just
showing you the ones
that the system comes with.
And associated with each
of these cluster roles
is a set of permissions for each
type of object in the system.
So this is just like a
dozen lines from the file.
The file's much longer, but
it doesn't fit on the screen.
So I'm just showing you
part of the definition
of what the admin cluster
role has access to.
So you can see here, it
has a list of resources
and sub-resources
associated with pods,
and a set of verbs
that are allowed
for someone with
the admin access
to do on those resources, like
create, delete, do a watch,
and so on.
So that was a cluster role, in
particular, the admin cluster
role.
And now what we're
going to do is
we're going to associate
that admin cluster
role with the blue user.
And the way that's done is by
creating a role binding object.
This looks a little complicated,
but it's not too bad.
What it's saying here is that
the user called the blue team
dev is going to get
the admin cluster
role in the blue namespace.
So that's what this is doing.
It's binding the blue user,
in particular their service
account, because we're
using service accounts.
But conceptually, it's the
blue user to the admin cluster
role in the blue namespace.
So now we ask the server
to create that binding.
And now we can go back to the
window with the blue user,
where previously, we saw
that they didn't have access
to the blue namespace.
And now when they
do kubectl get pods,
they get no resources found.
That's what we'd expect.
We haven't created
any pods yet, but you
see they're not getting the
permission denied error.
They're just being told that
the resources are not available
yet.
And they can do other things.
They can get services.
We haven't created
any services yet.
That's not too exciting.
They can run kubectl
run which creates
a deployment that
starts up a Nginx
server in the blue namespace.
So now, like I said, you can
see that they have permissions
in the blue namespace.
So now let's go back
to the Admin user,
and we're going to set up the
permissions for a green user.
So first, we create
a green user--
sorry, the green namespace,
and then another role binding.
This time the user is
the green team dev,
but it's the same permissions.
It's the admin cluster role.
It's being bound to
the green namespace.
So this is identical to the
last role binding we saw,
but instead of the blue
user, it's the green user,
and instead of the
blue namespace,
it's the green namespace.
And so let's create that.
And after we create that,
before we go and look
at what the green user can do,
let's go back to the blue user
and just verify that
they can't do anything
in this green namespace.
So we do kubectl get pods
in the green namespace.
You can see that
that's forbidden.
It gets services.
They can't see that
and they can't request
to see all namespaces either.
So the blue user,
as we intended,
doesn't have access in
the green namespace.
But we can go over to
the third window, which
is the one where we have
the green user set up,
and you can see that
they have permission
in the green namespace.
It's get pods, namespace green.
It says no resources found.
We haven't created
any resources,
but this shows they
have permission
to look at the resources.
They can't look in
the blue namespace,
because we didn't
give them permission
to look in the blue
namespace, but they
do have permission in
the green namespace.
They can run Nginx or
do whatever they want
inside the green namespace.
So now we have the blue
user with full permission
in the blue namespace, the
green user with full permission
in the green namespace.
And I'll show you
one last piece,
which is that view thing that
Alan mentioned a minute ago.
Let's say hypothetically that
the green user, in addition
to having permissions
to do whatever they want
in their green
namespace, also is
supposed to have
view permissions
in the blue namespace.
Maybe they're allowed to
monitor the objects that
are created by that blue user.
And so what we can do is that--
oh sorry, well, first
we'll show that the admin
user can see all the resources
in all of the namespaces.
So some of these are system
resources at the bottom,
but you can see
the top two lines
are the Nginx deployment
that we set up
that the blue user started and
that the green user started.
So now onto what I was
just saying a second ago.
We're going to create
a third role binding.
This is going to give
the view permission.
You can see down here,
cluster roll view.
It's going to give the view
permission to the green team
user, give them view permission
on the blue namespace.
So we create this role binding.
We can go back to the
window for the green user.
Do get deployments,
namespace blue,
and you can see that this
green user can view objects,
in particular, the deployment
objects in the blue namespace,
but they can't do
other mutations.
For example, this green user
can't do this kubectl Delete
and try to delete
the deployment,
because they only have
view access to it.
And so that's pretty
much the end of the demo.
Just showing again that
you can give fairly fine
grained access control to users
on a namespace granularity.
Giving them
permissions to create,
delete, view
objects, and a bunch
of different other
operations based
on what permissions
you're trying to set up.
So I'll hand it
back to you, Alan.
ALAN NAIM: Thank you.
So putting it all together
to summarize everything we've
talked about today so far.
Recommendation is break out
your operating environment,
in particular, production.
It's a separate project.
And then put your dev test
staging in another project.
And depending on the
requirements for your teams,
you could put them same cluster
or separate dev test staging
into different clusters.
Namespaces are a great boundary,
especially in Kubernetes 1.6
for having user level control.
So for cases where
you're running a cluster
with multiple
applications, you'll
be able to associate roles
with these underlying
namespace objects.
Leverage groups to encapsulate
the actual identity access
management roles.
You can create these groups
that actually map back
to your processes, and then
that's really the benefit
that they provide you.
Leverage Kubernetes namespaces
and assign resource quotas
for cases where you have
different departments,
different requirements
that are sharing resources,
and potentially, you
could have abuse.
So leverage these quotas to
actually avoid these situations
from happening.
And in cases where
you are running
heterogeneous applications
within a cluster, where you're
sharing cluster
resources, really start
thinking about using
requests and limits.
A scenario that not too many
people really understand,
but I think this is
something definitely
worth looking at and
using in the future,
actually, to provide the
best quality of service
for your applications as they
run within the environments.
And then take advantage
of some of these objects,
like initial resources, to
help you better understand
usage and utilization
for your containers.
That being said, here's
some links and resources.
There's much more we can
provide you, but the idea is--
for those of you that
are new to Kubernetes,
there's some phenomenal
training courses
that are available online.
And our documentation goes into
pretty much a lot of detail
as far as request
limits and using
those types of
quality of service
controls for your cluster.
That being said, I
will open it up to Q&A.
And perhaps, David, you
want to come back up,
and we'll take your questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I had a quick question about
the role-based access control
that you had shown in
the previous slide.
I saw that you use
service accounts.
Does it also work with user
accounts and Google Groups
if you use that?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: Yeah.
It works it works with user.
It definitely works
with user accounts.
Like I said, the only
reason we were using service
accounts there was because
it's hard to kind of log
in from multiple users
at the same time.
AUDIENCE: And this
is in 1.6, right?
And you were using it
against the cluster,
so the cluster is
upgraded to 1.6?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: No.
To be clear-- that's
a great question.
I was running against
a test cluster,
like an internal test
cluster that we have up.
So it's not available yet.
1.6 will be rolled out sometime
in the next month or so.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: For the instances
that are running on best effort
with overcommitment
of resources,
before something
would be evicted,
is there any type
of notification that
would happen for the workload
to say, hey, prepare myself
to go away?
Any type of warning, or would
it be an immediate eviction?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: No.
For the memory eviction, right
now there's no notification.
It's the system immediately
needs to reclaim the memory,
and so you get
evicted right away.
There's other kinds of
preemption type operations
in Kubernetes, like when
you're doing a rolling update
and you're restarting your
pod into a new container image
version and things like that,
where we do provide notice.
But this is kind of
the one situation
where there really
isn't an opportunity
to run some other code to
notify your application,
because there just isn't
any memory left on the node,
and so we kill it
without notification.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So you guys didn't
set any limits
on the amount of questions
that can be asked, right?
OK.
DAVID OPPENHEIMER:
Very good pun, yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I just have a few.
So the IAM stuff, it
only works in GCP, right?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: Not exactly.
So the fundamental role-based
access control mechanism
is part of open
source Kubernetes.
The tie-in into the
Google Cloud Platform
IAM, that's how we were
using the GCP service
accounts and stuff like that.
That part is only on
Google Cloud Platform,
but all of the
role-based access control
mechanisms, the
underlying stuff,
is all in the open source.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So it already works
in the AWS today?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: I
don't know how connected--
if people have done that
last mile of plumbing
to connect it to the
AWS IAM mechanism.
We have a special
interest group, Kubernetes
special interest
group for AWS, and you
can ask a question there.
I don't know the
answer to the question,
but in principle,
it's possible, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Also, are there any plans on
more granular authorization?
So I know you guys do the
namespace authorization.
It seems like that's
the lowest you go.
Are there any plans on not
allowing certain aspects
of the API to be used?
So say I don't want
someone to create
a storage set in a
certain role, or I
don't want them to
create something
without a health check,
or I don't want them
to open up a certain port--
things along those lines?
Or is that always going to be
above the Kubernetes level?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: I don't
have a good answer for that.
Today the lowest
level of granularity
is the namespace and sort of
what you can do in a namespace,
but in the future, there might
be those other possibilities.
I'm not aware of discussions
going on yet about that,
but those do seem like
reasonable use cases.
AUDIENCE: For the
CPU limiting, is
that done through some
combination of CPU throttling
or some sort of combination of
CPU affinity and throttling?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: So the
way it works under the covers
is that the CPU request maps to
CPU shares in the CFS scheduler
in the Linux kernel.
And the CPU limit maps
to some other CPU--
I don't remember the details.
Something else in the
kernel that throttles it.
So it's using kernel CPU
scheduling mechanisms
to enforce that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you're not pinning
it to a specific CPU.
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: No.
We don't have support yet
for pinning containers
to specific CPUs, and
that's not the mechanism
that's used there.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: In the beginning
you talked about people
splitting things up in
terms of just like projects,
or namespaces, or clusters.
Some were suggesting in
production people are running
services that are-- just
from my experience-- people
are running services
that are kind of similar.
So let's say I have a
bunch of stateful sets.
I have some things that
are running the JVMs,
so they need the JV memory,
or I have some Redis clusters.
Are people looking at
splitting these things up just
in terms of just namespaces?
Or is there kind of an incentive
to split this up by cluster?
Because then you
can optimize out
of the parameter setting
just by cluster instead
of having do it by namespace.
Are there any pros
and cons with that?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: I don't know.
Maybe Alan could talk.
Do you want to take that, or
do you want me to take that?
ALAN NAIM: Yeah.
It really depends
on your application.
But what we see
out there is people
are running these within
their own namespace
and sharing a
particular cluster.
There are cases, though,
where the applications have
certain data stringent
requirements that really
require true isolation from a
networking perspective as well,
and those are cases where
people end up splitting them up
into different clusters.
You want to add to that?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: Yeah.
I agree.
It kind of depends on what
specific kind of isolation
you're trying to achieve.
If you wanted to say more about
what you were trying to do,
we could give you
a recommendation.
You can do it now, or you
can do it after the talk.
It's up to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]